bienvenue dans PAF pas vous le savez ce
sont des débats sur des sujets
d'actualité on va parler des prix Nobel
on va parler d'Emmanuel Macron on va
parler de les quotas on va parler de
recherche aussi des débats avec avec une
bande que je vous présente avec Mustapha
lahbaoui bonjour bonjour vous êtes
pharmacien vous êtes président du
Football Club de Trappes très appliqué
dans la vie associative correcte et il y
a évidemment beaucoup de sujets de la
semaine qui vous ont intéressé je
suppose
Jean-Charles la joie dit bonjour bonjour
vous êtes éditeur
éditeur vous êtes dans les Yvelines
d'ailleurs absolument et vous aussi je
suppose qu'il y a beaucoup de sujets qui
vous ont intéressé oui oui la semaine
est assez riche
bonjour de restaurateur au Templiers et
vous êtes l'un des dirigeants du
Groupement National des indépendants qui
est un nouveau groupement
lundi et donc ça y est c'est parti c'est
une nouvelle vie qui commence par
l'organisation des hôteliers
restaurateurs cafetiers indépendants en
France près de 20 000 entreprises ça va
faire du bruit fait du bruit
bonjour Vous êtes étudiant première
année d'histoire c'est ça juste à côté
juste à côté là oui à Versailles
Saint-Quentin ça s'est bien passé cette
semaine la rentrée tout ça oui très bien
et puis une invité Isabelle bonjour je
suis ravi de vous recevoir vous êtes
vice-présente du conseil régional chargé
de l'enseignement supérieur de la
recherche donc conseiller régional vous
êtes conseillère municipal de Versailles
vous étiez présenté aussi aux élections
législatives vous êtes aussi la nouvelle
présidente du Génopole
alors d'abord juste une question de
vocabulaire comme ça est-ce qu'on peut
dire madame la Présidente ou madame le
Président
je crois que le débat est tranché et que
c'est bien parce que vous savez que ça
dépend
que c'est des choses qui sont derrière
nous l'essentiel quand même c'est que il
y a des femmes qui occupent des postes
de responsabilité et c'est vrai que
c'est un c'est un dossier qu'il faut que
collectivement homme et femme c'est pas
ça n'appartient pas qu'aux femmes il
faut que collectivement mes femmes on
avance là-dessus tranquillement je pense
qu'on va y revenir mais ça fait partie
de la nécessité de la diversification de
nos dirigeants quel qu'il soit dans tous
les domaines on a besoin que la société
française prenne un peu d'air et je
pense que les femmes ont peu amener un
peu dans des milieux qui sont souvent
très très masculins on peut amener la
place des femmes après il y a les
questions du vocabulaire alors
l'Académie française a quand même acté
que c'était
c'était pas ce qu'il fallait dire enfin
l'Assemblée nationale
à moins que vous ayez envie de supprimer
l'Académie française ça sert à rien
l'Académie française dit le français et
tout le monde semble bloquer les
Français s'adapte aussi
on était clairement dans un dossier
politique c'était un moment politique et
qui était quand même une façon de
contester l'autorité d'une femme qui
était vice-présidente en tribune et
c'était une façon extrêmement
désagréable de lui signifier que
peut-être que sa place était pas là donc
c'est ça qui est derrière je suis
extrêmement sensible au respect de la
langue française et
à son attention mais je pense que c'est
pas comme ça c'est pas avec des signaux
comme ça que on la fera qu'on la
renforcera je crois que derrière le
sujet était beaucoup plus un sujet
politique et c'est vrai que c'était
extrêmement désagréable l'insistance
avec laquelle ça en effet c'est ça le
sujet majeur et moins un sujet de langue
défendant la langue autrement je serai
avec vous défendons les éditeurs je
serai avec vous mais honnêtement sur ce
sujet là je crois que c'était autre
chose qui était en jeu
de dire peut-être aussi secret national
de PS en charge de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche que vous êtes
enseignante dans dans
l'académie française vous n'êtes pas
chercheuse vous êtes chercheur alors
parce qu'en fait je suis enseignant
chercheur c'est quand on est professeur
d'université on est enseignant chercheur
enfin je crois que là c'est pareil c'est
rentré dans les mœurs que dans l'usage
on dit chercheuse et on dit enseignante
et on dit donc enseignante chercheuse et
on dit
professeur
il y en a qui maintenant écrivent des
bouquins et qui sont maintenant
pratiquement des best-sellers sur la
féminisation de la société ça va au-delà
de la place
heureusement parlera peut-être mes
passions du jour notre livre Dimitri
vous vous êtes pour la féminisation des
titres ou des bien sûr oui à tout à fait
bon
alors on va parler un petit peu on va
parler de recherche mais d'abord un mot
quand même sur le sur les jeunes Paul
c'est qu'on appelle un biocluster c'est
ça alors il y a une vingtaine de
laboratoires il y a des pôles de
recherche il y a aussi une 70
entreprises qui qui sont nées de Paul
c'est effectivement une institution très
très intéressante et tout à fait
particulière dans dans ce paysage
tellement compliqué qui est celui de la
recherche française c'est un paysage
avec des institutions très diverses je
veux pas trop longue là-dessus mais
c'est vrai que c'est un paysage
compliqué qui fait aussi que
malheureusement et on espère qu'on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir
cette complexité fait que on voit pas on
voit pas trop un certain nombre de
choses le Génopole donc c'est une
institution très particulière
il va effectivement
d'élaboratoires de recherche
fondamentale sur la génomique
jusqu'à l'innovation c'est à dire la
valorisation économique de la recherche
et il y a effectivement des entreprises
qui sont présentes sur le territoire de
d'Évry autour du Génopole et dans le
Génopole et puis l'accès aux soins avec
quelque chose qui se développe
énormément et qui est-ce qu'on appelle
la médecine personnalisée qui va
probablement moi j'ai le sentiment que
on est à deux doigts du grand
bouleversement qu'on attend qu'on attend
depuis maintenant plusieurs dizaines
d'années que on est à deux doigts la
saillait parce que les la puissance
publique a vraiment porté ça de manière
très
forte la région où on a été très très
présent derrière ginopôle et là on a le
sentiment que ça y est ça va déboucher
ça va déboucher sur des avancées pour
les malades et pas seulement pour les
maladies aussi pour les maladies rares
mais beaucoup plus largement le cancer
va être bouleversé
le soin du cancer va être bouleversé par
par les avancées qui sont en train
d'être fait par les chercheurs et puis
bien au delà c'est pas seulement la
santé ça touche le
les carburants les biocarburants ça
touche plein de domaines avec la
génomique ces entreprises qui dépendent
du Génopole elles appartiennent à qui il
y a des chercheurs c'est des investir
privée c'est comment ça se passe
c'est des entreprises privées mais qui
bénéficient d'un certain nombre d'une
espèce de plateforme d'accompagnement et
puis de la proximité des laboratoires
donc c'est absolument
fondamental c'est un peu ce qu'on a du
mal à faire en France c'est qu'on a une
recherche fondamentale absolument
magnifique
et on a du mal à aller chercher dans les
laboratoires les connaissances pour les
amener à la valorisation valorisation
économique dans des entreprises mais
aussi valorisation qui permettent la
transition énergétique donc le
développement durable et puis le soin on
a beaucoup de mal à faire ça et là c'est
vrai que le fait que sur le même endroit
vous ayez des entreprises et des
chercheurs ça aide à faire ça et ça
c'est on voit que là ça va être moi j'ai
beaucoup d'espoir que ça va avancer très
très vite et que ça va être formidable
pour la région pour pour nous tous on
dirait que c'est un modèle ce jeu de
pôle pour la pour la recherche française
justement ce lien entre la recherche
fondamentale recherche appliquée c'est
en effet il faut pas je pense que là on
est dans un moment où la recherche oui
c'est un domaine particulier c'est dans
un territoire particulier c'est une
histoire particulière donc je pense que
en ce moment il faut faire un effort
majeur sur la recherche faire un effort
majeur pour la valorisation de la
recherche mais je suis enfin je pense
qu'il faut un peu marquer le pas sur les
bouleversements institutionnels c'est un
milieu contrairement à l'image qui peut
avoir qui a connu réforme sur
après en particulier des années noires
qui ont été les années
Sarkozy avec une espèce de brutalité
dans la mise en place des réformes
j'étais très impliqué à ce moment-là
c'est comme ça que voilà j'ai décidé de
faire ce moment de ma vie en
politiquement
vous avez été la présidence de sauver la
recherche c'était c'était en effet sous
le quinquennat de Nicolas Sarkozy ou un
moment vous pensez que la recherche
était menacée et c'est comme ça que vous
êtes vous êtes du père j'étais très j'ai
toujours été extrêmement politisé mais
au bon sens du terme c'est très
préoccupé d'un certain nombre de de
problématiques politiques
et très concerné par les questions
écologistes et en même temps je pense
que je fais partie d'une génération
où l'engagement a été compliqué pour moi
l'engagement politique donc j'avais
décidé que moi mon engagement mon
inscription politique je la faisais dans
mon métier donc c'est pas par hasard que
je suis prof à l'Université de Paris 13
à Villetaneuse quand même voilà dans le
paysage francilien un territoire
particulier donc je le portais comme ça
et puis c'est vrai qu'il y a eu
au moment de du quinquennat de Nicolas
Sarkozy j'ai eu le sentiment que non ça
ne pouvait pas ça ne pouvait plus aller
que on était dans un moment de notre
histoire absolument incroyable j'en suis
de plus en plus convaincue avec une
gravité du moment dans lequel on est
extrêmement fort et que il fallait que
je passe en politique et on est venu me
chercher après le mouvement de 2009 on
m'a posé Jean-Paul Huchon qui m'a
proposé d'être sur ses listes dans les
Yvelines et donc à ce moment là j'ai
accepté c'était j'ai beaucoup hésité
j'ai beaucoup hésité parce que j'adore
mon métier je continue à l'exercer
j'adore mon métier j'adore
l'enseignement j'adore la recherche
j'adore ce milieu là que je trouve
formidable mais en même temps je
trouvais que il fallait y aller et
d'autant plus que je pense que
aujourd'hui on a besoin de de modifier
la représentation nationale et la
représenter de nos élus on a besoin de
gens qui sont voilà qui sont prises
société civile oui mais en même temps on
est tous issus la société civile mais en
tous les cas qui ont une inscription
politique
dans un dans un milieu une compétence
avec une compétence même si c'est pas
facile dans les appareils politiques et
dans les partis politiques c'est pas
facile des trajectoires comme la mienne
mais je suis plus déterminée que jamais
à l'idée que s'il faut y aller donc
engagez-vous allez-y on vous a envoyé
vous avez été candidate à Versailles
municipal au législatives aussi est-ce
que vous avez l'impression que vous avez
un peu
je suis élue des Yvelines
et en même temps moi je ne me sentais
pas en 2012 au moment où ça s'est décidé
je ne me sentais pas en capacité
d'exercer un mandat de parlementaire je
trouvais que deux ans dans la vie
politique c'était trop juste et que il
faut quand même même si j'exerce à la
région une responsabilité
conséquente mais c'est pas la même chose
que
d'être parlementaires et donc je voulais
bien participer à l'effort national et
donc parce que mener des législatives
c'est aussi mener la campagne nationale
présidentielle on appuie ça se fait en
même temps j'étais dans l'équipe de Brie
après j'étais auprès de Peillon sur le
secteur Enseignement supérieur et
recherche et donc je voilà je disais je
veux bien y aller mais je me sens pas
mûre pour porter une campagne
législative et devenir parlementaire
et donc
pouvez accepter d'aller sur une
circonscription qu'on savait très très
difficile on a fait un score enfin où
j'ai fait un score enfin je dis honte
parce que c'est toute une équipe qui est
derrière on a fait un score qui
franchement était plus que plus que
correct
voilà je mais c'est vrai que j'avais ce
moment de d'interrogations
simplement attention au cumul des
mandats parce qu'on voit déjà la région
vous êtes sur l'Île-de-France vous êtes
sur la commune de Versailles on a parlé
de la députation de la circonscription
faudra juste faire attention
et si je peux me permettre c'est
intéressant parce que c'est vrai qu'on
est très intéressé autour de cette table
à faire rentrer de plus en plus de gens
dit de la société cible mais en réalité
on l'est tous sauf que ce sont des gens
souvent qui sont des professionnels
voilà c'est en ça on dit la société
civile mais curieusement vous avez
commencé par dire je suis rentré en
politique il y a eu quasiment un choc
dans votre vie vous êtes rentré en
politique et en même temps vous prenez
garde de dire de la bonne manière
aussi ce mot peut rentrer en politique
aujourd'hui devenait presque
compliqué énoncer vous avez dit oui mais
j'en fais de bonnes manières on se sent
aujourd'hui obligé de le dire comme ça
je pense que c'est un vrai problème
c'est un vrai problème et c'est une
vraie question qu'il faut en permanence
se poser vous avez raison sur le cumul
des mandat alors je pense que je suis
une élue qui cumule mais en même temps
je n'ai qu'un mandat avec une une
rémunération c'est celui de la
vice-président de la Région tous les
autres un Génopole tout ça c'est pas du
cumul de mandat parce qu'il y a toujours
cette idée derrière le cumul le mandat
qui est il y a des gens cumulent de
rémunération je tiens un ratio mais
c'est vrai qu'en termes d'exercice je le
sens je trouve que j'exerce beaucoup de
responsabilités je pense que ça ne
pourra pas éternellement durer comme ça
il faudra à un moment que je fasse des
choix mais pour l'instant j'arrive à
l'assumer je pense que tous mes mandats
je les exerce avec beaucoup de
détermination je suis présente à
Versailles je suis extrêmement présente
à la région je suis présente au Parti
socialiste et je suis devant mes
étudiants toutes les semaines je
commence par 6 heures d'amphi le lundi
matin
pour ma part
comme tout un chacun autour de cette
table bien sûr et c'est de savoir le
mieux possible qui vous étiez et on ne
peut qu'admirer une femme comme vous
évidemment en même temps ce que je
constate très souvent c'est que les
politiciens de métiers font entrer des
gens comme vous dans leur cercle pour se
donner bonne conscience il ferait bien
de vous donner aussi le pouvoir pas
seulement la parole
on me confie quand même des
responsabilités en secrétaire national
des parties socialiste
alors je peux vous dire que à la région
le mandat que j'exerce Jean Peluchon est
un homme qui a une qualité absolument
enfin qui a beaucoup de qualité mais une
en particulier que j'ai pu constater
c'est le fait de faire une confiance
extrêmement forte c'est à dire que
vraiment il m'a laissé mener une
politique dont je suis extrêmement fière
extrêmement fier on fait des choses on
n'est pas dans nos compétences propres
mais la politique qu'on mène sur la
recherche et l'enseignement supérieur je
peux vous dire que vraiment j'ai exercé
mon mandat j'ai exercé du pouvoir mais
au bon sens du terme c'est-à-dire le
sentiment de pouvoir faire avancer les
choses pour les étudiants pour les
chercheurs que ça bouge et aux parties
socialiste ma parole est entendue quand
je dis des choses c'est tout nouveau
mais j'ai pas le sentiment de n'être
qu'une caution qu'on envoie dans des
missions impossibles sur des
circonscriptions perdus j'ai vraiment
pas ce sentiment
sentiment que si je peux faire avancer
les choses le jour où je peux plus c'est
simple j'arrête
revenons au thème de la recherche
puisque justement votre engagement
c'était vous avez été la présidence de
sauver la recherche c'était en 2009
est-ce que vous diriez fille alors vous
appuyez un changement de majorité de vos
vœux est-ce que vous direz que le
changement de majorité l'arrivée de la
gauche au pouvoir a changé les choses on
partir de recherche et d'enseignements
supérieurs alors c'était très
con exercice c'était un exercice très
compliqué comme dans tous les secteurs
je pense dire que la brutalité du
pouvoir sarkozyme
de mener les réformes avec une
incapacité de dialoguer le milieu de la
recherche était un milieu qui avait
demandé en 2004 à mon mouvement il sort
de 2004 on met en place des étages zéro
de la recherche dans lequel on fait un
certain monde un certain nombre de
recommandations donc c'est un mouvement
propositionnel on propose des choses
pour faire évoluer dans le bon sens le
milieu de la recherche et l'enseignement
supérieur et là vous avez un pouvoir
Sarkozy qui arrive qui fait semblant de
diaguer avec les gens qui fait les
choses avec une brutalité absolument
incroyable ce qui a fait qu'on s'est
retrouvé dans la rue parce que on croit
toujours que les universités c'est on
est dans la rue les chercheurs on est
tout le temps en train de râler que
c'est un milieu en ébullition permanente
d'habitude c'est les étudiants qui sont
dans la rue les enseignants chercheurs
les chercheurs c'est très rare et donc
là il y a eu un mouvement de
méditation absolument immense en 2009
face à un pouvoir et en particulier
Valérie Pécresse qui était ministre
intransigeant ne voulant pas entendre ce
qu'on disait et ça a laissé vraiment des
traces d'où la difficulté de l'exercice
au genre d'huile c'est-à-dire que il
faut à la fois
je vais y venir il faut à la fois faire
des réformes et en même temps les faire
dans doucement donc il faut changer les
choses ce qu'il faut je pense c'est dire
où est-ce qu'on veut être dans 20 ans
dans 20 ans ça veut dire où est-ce qu'on
est dans 10 ans ou est-ce qu'on est dans
5 ans et qu'est-ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui c'est des trucs très très
longs c'est des réformes très lourdes
sur un secteur essentiel et sur l'argent
et sur l'argent oui j'adore je vais j'ai
lu de pain sur l'argent il y a un effort
de maintien moi j'ai fait une conférence
de presse du Parti socialiste en disant
il faut un effort supplémentaire là on a
une situation c'est un secteur tellement
important c'est c'est celui de la
qualification tout le monde c'est celui
de l'avenir il faut notre chance on a en
plus une chance incroyable de voir la
recherche qu'on a en France comme je le
disais tout à l'heure donc je crois que
il y a nécessité d'un investissement
supplémentaire parce que là aussi la
droite a laissé un bilan extrêmement
lourd notamment dans les universités
notamment cette juste à côté sur est-ce
que ça a été assez vite il y a des
choses malheureusement ça ne se dit pas
assez il y a eu quand même un certain
nombre de réformes qui ont été faites et
qui permettront de recréer un dispositif
global avec les regroupements
d'établissements même s'il faut prendre
le temps de le faire dans ça devient un
peu technique mais ce qu'on appelle des
communes c'est-à-dire au niveau régional
on regroupe les établissements
université école donc on est en train de
traiter cette question de la dualité
université école qui est quelque chose
qui qui fait que la société française va
pas bien et que on a une reproduction
des dirigeants très très forts
on a il en France dans le système
d'enseignement supérieur un système très
très compliqué qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
vous retrouver dans les premiers cycles
universitaires très souvent les
étudiants qui cumulent les fragilités
parce que les bons mais non et parce
qu'on en a des formidables enfin il y en
a mais cumulent cumuler les fragilités
ça veut pas dire que c'est pas des bons
étudiants ça veut dire que c'est les
gens souvent notamment les étudiants des
milieux les plus défavorisés les gamins
de Trappes le seul choix qu'ils aient
c'est d'aller à l'université en premier
cycle et heureusement et au foot et au
foot et au foot donc ça on a il y a eu
quand même une réforme qui a consisté à
remettre un peu les choses dans le bon
ordre pour éviter le truc où vont à
l'université les enfants qui cumulent
les jeunes qui cumulent les difficultés
de manière à reporter deux objectifs qui
sont
amener 50% d'une classe d'âge un diplôme
d'enseignement supérieur et on en a
besoin parce qu'on a besoin de monter en
gamme que notre pays monte en dagam qui
est une qualification plus importante
donc on a besoin de ça et un retour de
la démocratisation de l'enseignement
supérieur on en a besoin aussi c'est le
dynamisme de notre pays
un mot pardon parce qu'il faut qu'on
avance parce que il y a une bonne
nouvelle pour la recherche cette semaine
c'est quand même le on a eu deux prix
Nobel modiado pour la littérature et
gentirole pour l'économie c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour les chercheurs
français je suppose donc c'est une très
bonne nouvelle mais moi je vais pas
bouder mon plaisir mais ça fait très
longtemps ça fait très très longtemps
que je considère que
on pourrait faire encore mieux si parce
que le ils sont là ils sont dans les
laboratoires je peux vous dire qu'il y a
un nombre de physiciens de chimiste de
biologiste qui sont des gens mais de top
niveau internation vraiment c'est des
gens c'est incontestable et il y a un
travail à faire vous savez comment
marche les prix Nobel c'est souvent des
histoires de réseaux c'est des histoires
de réseaux et on n'arrive pas à les
révéler donc il faut absolument les
révéler en économie il y a une école
française de l'économie très
mathématisée donc qui a réussi à percer
et c'est tant mieux mais maintenant il
faut qu'on se retrousse les manches pour
que tous ceux-là qu'on a et qui sont des
personnalités mais vous pouvez pas
savoir à quel point c'est des gens
exceptionnels que tous les on les révèle
ils font un travail formidable mais il
faut les mettre en lumière davantage il
faut les remercier c'est des gens qui
travaillent pour nous au quotidien et et
vraiment c'est donc je me réjouis et en
même temps encore un effort il y en a
d'autres il faut qu'on les pousse
j'ai bien entendu la méthode de Sarkozy
c'est un peu cruel on est plutôt à
rechercher la méthode consensuelle le
dernier prix Nobel c'est plutôt de la
dynamite c'est de la dynamique pour le
gouvernement parce que il prône le
contrat unique enfin du CDD fin du CDI
c'est vrai que ça remet sur la table un
sujet extrêmement extrêmement explosif
pour parler du prix Nobel alors
l'économie est une discipline
extrêmement complète c'est pas vous je
vais apprendre ça c'est une discipline
extrêmement complexe ou il y a des
points de vue divergents chez les
économistes donc
il y a pas il y a pas enfin c'est pas il
y a pas la science économique il y a des
sciences économiques des discours
économiques des théories et sauf que le
sien il est très clair
des économistes formidables et une
économie en crise alors ça c'est un
autre question
du système mais c'est clair vous avez
des paroles vous avez des paroles
d'économistes qui disent très clairement
faut une flexibilité accrue du marché du
travail puis il y en a d'autres qui sont
en désaccord avec ça donc ça n'enlève
aucune pertinence à ce que peut dire le
prix Nobel mais je pense qu'il faut
faire de la politique c'est s'appuyer
sur des travaux d'économiste et pas
forcément prendre comme une vérité
absolument révélée ce que dit l'un
d'entre eux fustile aussi
prestigieux il réouvre enfin le débat
était ouvert avant quand
pas par les tests du prix Nobel afin que
vous voulez partager pas totalement mais
moi je voudrais juste vous poser une
question parce que il a dit une chose
alors là que je partage absolument pas
parce que on a beaucoup repris
es mais il y a eu un autre point qu'il a
dit juste après c'était le fait qu'il
fallait rien investir dans la recherche
et l'éducation ça je signe il y a 200 %.
est-ce que le modèle de son de son école
de Toulouse et est un modèle qui devrait
être multiplié parce que il a monté
quand même quelque chose de particulier
à Toulouse avec cette école ou tous les
cours sont en anglais avec une sorte de
partenariat public privé enfin c'est
assez intéressant est-ce que c'est la
seule structure de ce type là est-ce
qu'il y en a d'autres est-ce que vous
appelez ça de vos vœux est-ce que non
alors ça c'est une là on ouvre un
dossier qui a un dossier compliqué et si
on rentre dans les institutions de la
recherche et l'enseignement supérieur je
disais tout à l'heure à quel point c'est
complexe mais bon c'est je ne pense pas
que ça soit un modèle généralisable
c'est un modèle très particulier
où il les entreprises sont venues en
appui
à cette école économique de Toulouse on
a vu par exemple l'école économique de
Paris a eu plus de mal alors qu'il y a
des gens comme Piketty qui était là ça a
été plus compliqué ça veut dire que le
financement privé de la recherche
publique c'est quelque chose en France
qui est compliqué ça ne ça ne fonctionne
pas comme ça et on a des institutions
publiques et moi je suis attaché à un
service public de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la Recherche même si
j'ai dit mon attention au privé
donc je ne pense pas que ça soit une
solution généralisable du tout en
revanche si la question c'est celle du
rapprochement entre les universités et
le monde privé il faut sortir des
caricatures ça fait très longtemps que
ces deux mondes se sont rapprochés il
faut sortir de l'idée que les
universitaires c'est des gens hors-sol
qui sont indifférents à l'insertion
professionnelle de leurs étudiants pour
qu'ils mots entreprise c'est un gros mot
c'est c'est plus du tout du tout la
réalité c'est plus du tout la réalité
mais le financement privé de la
recherche publique pourquoi pas moi
j'aimerais bien faut faire attention à
la dépendance de la recherche puisqu'on
a des dossiers quand même sur les un
financement privé de recherche ça peut
être compliqué on sait que ça peut être
compliqué mais il y a pas de raison de
s'opposer à un financement privé du
public le seul truc c'est qu'on constate
que c'est ça ne fonctionne pas comme ça
en France on avait mis en place au
moment de
fonctionner très très atypique c'est une
recherche très particulière
surdoué pour avoir monté ça non c'est
une recherche très particulière
d'économie avec des types de recherche
qui ont fait que ça a intéressé les
industriels c'est de l'économie
industrielle ça a intéressé ça a
intéressé les industriels donc c'est
c'est très c'est un cas vraiment
particulier qui à mon avis est pas
généralisable
je suis pas certain que ça intéresse
directement aux Comé de cuisine ou en
petits serveur mais en même temps je
crois que dans le domaine de l'économie
il y a un grand nombre il faut
déverrouiller et la problématique que
vous exposez
nous indiquant d'abord que c'est
extrêmement compliqué
nous est finalement désagréable pardon
mais oui l'économie c'est certainement
très compliqué
cet homme prix Nobel fait l'admiration
de tous au plan international et nous
nous ont réjouissons il est français
fantastique la cascade de mauvaise
nouvelle que nous avons depuis
pratiquement 2 ans il est peut-être
temps qu'on a quelques bonnes donc c'est
bien mais en même temps il est clair
aujourd'hui que
cet homme n'a absolument pas la solution
pour sortir d'une situation de laquelle
les Français ont envie de se sortir
aujourd'hui le travail ne paye plus il
est découragé même et à un moment donné
il faut juste que les économistes
imaginent que la simplification de notre
approche de cette économie c'est juste
récompenser le travail et oui et donc
pour en revenir à la politique bravo
pour ce que vous faites
bien sûr que nous sommes dans un pays et
je l'ai dit lors de notre dernière
émission qui marche
la tête à l'envers aujourd'hui c'est pas
le peuple qui a le pouvoir et c'est bien
dommage il est très mal représenté je
l'ai déjà dit dans cette émission donc
normalement les politiques devraient
simplement se soumettre à ce que le
peuple leur dit et Dieu sait c'est
pourtant il leur dit fort mais il ne
s’assume pas vivre et pire encore c'est
que finalement on se rend compte et dans
vos propos on le sent que les
administrations ont le plein pouvoir
dans ce pays et un moment donné il va
falloir sortir de là il va falloir que
les administrations obéissent aux
politiques et que les politiques
obéissent au peuple voilà à partir de là
on remarchera sur nos deux pattes
arrières et je pense que les choses
iront iront mieux vous voyez c'est pas
très compliqué moi je n'ai pas votre
science je suis
issu d'un modeste c'est que je voulais
vous dire oui bien entendu je comprends
que l'économie se soit extrêmement
complexe oui d'accord mais en même temps
comprenez que des millions de gens eux
ne comprennent pas à la complexité de
l'économie et je dise bon sang de
bonsoir qu'est-ce que je fais de mon
avenir et de celui de mes enfants
aujourd'hui et ben il semblerait que je
ne sois pas écouté et c'est probablement
le problème majeur de ce pays c'est pas
un point de droit ou de gauche moi je
n'ai pas à prendre position sur le plan
politique je suis un syndicaliste le
syndicaliste fait de la politique mais
il ne prend pas parti moi qui suis dans
la représentation de mes amis
entrepreneurs indépendants
c'est d'être une force de pour résumer
la politique
si on voyait comment fonctionner les
entreprises etc
comme Madame soit beaucoup plus
nombreuses dans la politique
l'encourager mais je vous encourage
madame bien entendu quelque part
je vous dis simplement l'essentiel
c'est-à-dire que oui madame c'est très
compliqué
dans le domaine de l'université et des
études supérieures j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir une de mes filles qui a fait
cela et je me réjouis c'est de brianz
études elle est sortie avec une mention
très bien sur une thèse qu'elle a
soumise à l'université de 50 ans
d'ailleurs en
1999 et cette thèse elle a eu la
meilleure note et une mention très bien
c'était comment sortir des 35 heures
vous voyez que déjà dans la famille on
est à peu près on est à peu près
des choses deux choses
j'entends ce que vous dites en même
temps moi je trouve que le discours
systématique de eux les politiques c'est
plus possible les politiques on est et
on ne doit être simplement que les
représentants élus par le suffrage
démocratique de nos concitoyens mais ça
veut dire ça veut dire qu'il faut que
nos concitoyens
s'engagent politiquement
ce renseigne sorte de la démagogie ne se
laisse pas embarquer par des idées
toutes faites toutes vendues il faut
qu'il y ait on est on est un pays
incroyablement politique et je trouve
que en ce moment il y a une espèce de de
repli de refus de la part de nos
concitoyens
dans un moment qui a un moment
historique je le redis c'est on est dans
une situation extrêmement compliquée on
est dans une situation extrêmement
compliquée je pense qu'il faut que
collectivement il y a un espèce de
réengagement plus serein moins hystérisé
moins instrumentalisée par des forces
qui sont quand même des forces qui
n'apporteront aucun débouché politique
aucun débouché politique et le problème
majeur c'est non seulement le vote Front
national en ce moment qui est
irrépressible mais c'est aussi
l'abstention il faut qu'on arrête avec
ça alors c'est vrai que c'est vrai alors
justement c'était le deuxième point
c'était le deuxième point les politiques
ne sont plus visibles ils ne sont plus
crédibles
regardez ma trajectoire
regardez ma trajectoire moi je
n'attendais pas ça je n'attendais pas ça
en même temps il y a eu un moment où
effectivement j'ai pris la parole j'ai
pris la parole fortement en disant ça
suffit c'est plus possible voilà ce
qu'il faut faire voilà mes propositions
etc et quand on fait ça je pense que
quand on fait ça et bien c'est possible
alors peut-être qu'effectivement comme
je le disais tout à l'heure
les appareils politiques ont encore du
mal à s'ouvrir mais venez venez venez me
soutenir venez avec moi engagez-vous la
deuxième chose la deuxième chose c'est
j'allais utiliser le terme de confiance
pour revenir sur la question économique
c'est vrai que c'est on y peut rien
l'économie c'est multi contrainte
c'est-à-dire que vous avez plein de
contraintes à prendre en même temps donc
c'est des systèmes incroyablement
complexes on y peut rien c'est comme ça
c'est la réalité non non on y peut rien
sur ces factuel sur la complexité des
phénomènes ensuite il y a un élément
quand même qui est central c'est le fait
que la dimension de confiance est une
dimension majeure dans toute cette
affaire une dimension majeure en
économie et il faut absolument que
collectivement on retrouve une confiance
alors qui est des nécessités de
simplification je pense que tout le
monde en est conscient aujourd'hui que
il y ait un poids beaucoup trop lourd
des contraintes administratives qui
entravent un certain nombre d'actions
qui entravent cette ce sens enfin c'est
pousser collectif qu'on pourrait avoir
dans un pays parce que il faut aussi par
moment on se réjouissait je me
réjouissais des prix Nobel en disant
mais en fait on pourra encore faire
mieux mais je me réjouis évidemment des
prix Nobel mais ce que je dis sur la
recherche on peut le dire sur la culture
on va en parler tout à l'heure on peut
le dire sur nos services publics on a
une chance incroyable avec ses services
publics les universités qu'on a les
hôpitaux il y a des problèmes mais on a
quand même une structure incroyable on a
un pays absolument magnifique qui attire
le monde entier donc on a plein de
potentiels on a plein de potentiels mais
on a ce sentiment
dépressif de déclinistes de de qui font
sortir donc il faut sortir dans les prix
Nobels
la littérature alors vous avez dit
quelque chose d'intéressant mais j'ai
pas entendu développement tout à l'heure
on connaît un pays grâce à c'est
vraiment policier
le meilleur moyen imaginons que vous
n'ayez jamais mis les pieds aux
États-Unis vous achetez deux bouquins de
James el Roy vous saurez exactement où
il faut aller à Los Angeles le quartier
à éviter le bon restaurant
Le roman policier des choses de
c'est un portrait absolument exact de
tout ce qui se passe dans les pays sans
Antonio magada mais c'était quand même
une vision quand même enfin moi je j'ai
une vision franche regarde
qui fait rêver
de ma référence en littérature
de voir qu'un écrivain qui fait la Une
de 20h c'est toujours c'est toujours
intéressant je connais assez mal
l'oeuvre de Patrick Modiano certains
m'ont découragé de le lire mais
une fois qu'on connaît
pas et qui est absolument abordable il
faut y aller
il y a un livre évidemment qui se vend
comme des petits pains c'est celui-là
dire Mustapha vous avez voulu l'acheter
vous l'avez même pas trouvé non mais je
n'ai pas trouvé donc j'étais obligé de
le télécharger
la France se couche la France se meurt
tout le monde en parle donc je préfère
parler des choses que j'ai lu alors je
sais pas s'il faudrait pas changer par
jour il y a un phénomène
ça veut dire quelque chose
voilà donc ça s'appelle
donc ça s'appelle le suicide de français
le suicide français je me demande c'est
pas le suicide de Zemmour on a vraiment
l'impression qu'il s'est attaqué à tout
le monde dans ce bouquin donc c'est
c'est bien fait c'est des 40 dernières
années
chrono et il revisite tout le monde
visite les footballeurs ils revissent
mais sur le phénomène parce que c'est
quand même quand on voit 5000
exemplaires par jour c'est quand même un
phénomène mais qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire il y a un public c'était mieux
avant on a reçu on a reçu
François-Xavier Bellamy j'évoquais déjà
le sujet à l'époque c'est ce fameux
c'était mieux avant et c'est vrai que
c'est plus confortable c'est beaucoup
plus confortable ce genre de bouquin
rencontre un succès
c'est la sortie de l'euro c'est pas du
tout on était mieux avant c'est surtout
au-delà de du contenu et des chapitres
et des chapitres plus ou moins
déplaisants plus ou moins plaisants sur
lequel on peut être d'accord ou pas
d'accord ce qui fait le succès de ça
c'est pas que c'était mieux avant c'est
surtout qu'il ne pense pas comme tout le
monde et maintenant en France on ne peut
plus qu'on a tout petit peu différent on
est tout de suite etc non mais il a un
vrai fan club
finalement
est-ce que c'est pas des gens qui se
demandent mais pourquoi on en est arrivé
là
mais si justement parce que c'était
mieux avant on pourrait arriver là
d'abord les rubriques
dans les magazines dans lesquels il est
sont extrêmement lus c'est
chroniqueurs
le discours de ce bonhomme correspond
effectivement à une espèce de contre
politiquement correct quelque part
c'est-à-dire que on est dans une
situation pardon chez madame ou dès que
on pense un peu en dehors des autres et
en dehors des clous on a immédiatement
vilipender juger montrer du doigt bon ce
garçon est montré du doigt moi j'ai pas
lu cet ouvrage j'ai pas eu le temps de
le lire j'en ai lu deux autres que
j'avais trouvé extrêmement intéressant
j'avais lu le premier siècle moi j'avais
trouvé plutôt bien la façon qu'ils
décrivait le rapport féminisation de la
société il a pas tort
et puis j'ai lu la mélancolie française
il me semble assez intéressant même si
comme ça ils peuvent pas être assez
contestables qui est de dire si les
femmes arrivent au politique c'est que
la politique n'a plus de pouvoir ah
c'est un grand argument moi je voudrais
revenir sur le continent
parce qu'on peut panier que la politique
a perdu de pouvoir par rapport à ce que
oui président Hollande aujourd'hui a
beaucoup moins de pouvoir qu'on en avait
mis des rangs
le thème central de son groupe
de choses qu'à un moment donné
effectivement là vous voyez bien vous le
dites d'ailleurs vous-même on est au
bord de la crise de nerfs c'est la
déprime généralisée alors ces bouquins
la plaie finalement c'est comme un
miroir
est un peu en parallèle avec tout ça
évidemment je disais l'autre jour que
les Français ont envie de renverser la
table les Français ont envie de se que
tout ça change de se remettre debout
d'être fier ils le sont plus bon il faut
redonner de la fierté je n'ai pas lu cet
ouvrage mais c'est vrai que dans
notamment la mélancolie française il
retrace un petit peu tout ce qui s'est
passé en Europe pas seulement en France
d'ailleurs sur cette envie qu'on tous
les hommes et femmes de pouvoir
d'essayer de rebâtir l'Empire romain
avec tout ce que la concerne en matière
de culture d'écon fini de travail etc et
de valorisation des individus bon bah
cet homme est sur cette vague là Marine
Le Pen elle est un peu Bonaparte
regarder le succès
aujourd'hui
donc voilà c'est une vision qu'il a lui
et je pense qu'il a pour le coup une
grande majorité des Français qui pensent
comme lui réfère le référendum alors
je pense pas que c'est un rapport avec
le Front national par contre je dirais
plus loin que le Front national tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui est effectivement
chère Madame infréquentable
parce que les personnalités qui le
dirigent malheureusement en ont fait une
espèce de de partie
beaucoup beaucoup il y a il y a dans
d'autres parties mais c'est la raison
pour laquelle moi j'essaie d'accepter
que les Français veuillent sortir des
parties sont assez les Français de ce
clivage droite-gauche ils en ont assez
de toutes ces parties il y a plein de
types de gens connais quelques-uns des
gars très bien je pense à demi père par
exemple qui a essayé de monter à la
partie qui bien de loin il est brillant
intellectuellement il a essayé de monter
un parti il s'est fait laminer en
l'espace de 3 mois voilà donc les
Français veulent sortir de la et lui là
il a un discours ben ma foi qui navigue
entre tout ça pas trop mal et oui ça
ressemble un petit peu à ce que les
Français pensent profondément
la première c'est que c'est quand même
une construction c'est aussi une
construction c'est à dire que ça fait 10
minutes qu'on parle d'Éric Zemmour et
donc les ventes d'Éric Zemmour vont
continuer et il
occupe c'est ce que vous appelez je
crois dans le jardin
un bon client c'est un bon client parce
que c'est un type qui systématiquement
et dans la provocation le on brise les
tabous et moi je pense que c'est pas
comme ça alors sauf si on veut vendre
des livres effectivement mais si on a un
peu de responsabilité et qu'on veut
avoir une parole qui est une parole qui
s'inscrit dans le moment dans lequel on
est on fait pas des choses comme ça ça
c'est la première chose que je voulais
dire c'est
la première chose que je voulais dire la
deuxième chose c'est que je pense que
effectivement il porte des thèmes et des
thèses qui sont dangereuses qui ouvrent
les vannes c'est pas le seul à avoir des
responsabilités je pense que quand
la droite à 10 des choses sur l'identité
tout le discours sur l'identité
l'instrumentalisation de l'immigration
des étrangers la préférence nationale
etc c'est des choses il faut arrêter
avec ça il faut arrêter avec ça on a
besoin de toute cette richesse on a
besoin de regarder les choses
positivement la posture de dénonciation
la posture démagogique ça fait pas
avancer les choses on est dans un moment
où vraiment on n'a pas besoin de ça et
moi je vraiment je trouve ça extrêmement
préoccupant et je pense qu'il faut qu'on
arrête d'en parler il faut qu'on arrête
d'en parler et que on arrête de
l'inviter tout le temps parce que sinon
ça va ça va être
effectivement lire ce livre on peut
réellement aller chapitre
ils ont Tirol
ces sujets
comme ça non vous avez besoin juste on a
sur tous les sujets qui ont été abordés
sur la question de l'immigration sur la
question de la préférence nationale sur
la question tous les toutes les sur la
question de l'Europe de la souveraineté
sur la question de l'entité
l'antisémitisme sur la question sur
toutes ces questions vous avez des des
chercheurs qui travaillent de façon
extrêmement précise argumentées qui ont
des tas de choses à dire j'aimerais
qu'il soit invité de temps en temps à la
place d'Eric Zemmour
ils apprendraient être des bons clients
et il serait appuyé sur des
connaissances qui sont solides et non
pas sur un truc démocrates Dimitri veux
simplement dire lisons Marcel Proust
parce que j'ai interviewé d'ailleurs le
tête-à-tête passe en ce moment sur TV
fils Raphaël Enthoven qui a écrit un
livre sur Marcel Proust qui qui dit en
lisant Proust tristesse et nos joies
plus intéressantes donc voilà plutôt que
de lire Eric Zemmour se pencher sur en
lisant par scène prouston
en arrière mais c'est vrai que je pense
que c'est quelqu'un qui est à mon avis
qu'il faut lire quand même lui ou
d'autres qui propose ce genre de
discours ce genre de vue parce qu'à mon
nez le débat est important madame parler
de consensus tout à l'heure il faut
qu'on puisse débattre il faut qu'on
puisse trouver des sorties ensemble pas
simplement un clan c'est ça le truc
c'est qu'il faut poser les termes du
débat au bon endroit
et du coup ils nous emmène
c'est l'assimilation ou l'intégration
des immigrés il préférait l'assimilation
à l'intégration il y en a un qui sait
très bien d'intégrer je pense on va en
parler c'est Omar Sy dans le film sans
bas enfin c'est pas son film à lui qu'il
intervient principal de samba qui sort
et qui est sorti mercredi je propose de
regarder la bande-annonce et on en parle
après
ok alors je t'explique en gros si on a
48 heures pour aider à sortir un fois
moins donc faut se manier
bonjour c'est quoi votre nom
depuis plusieurs années déjà j'avais
fait une demande de titre de séjour et
moi embarqué de
je vais te donner un conseil faut garder
la distance parce qu'après ça peut
vraiment faire mal s'ils sont envoyés
c'est fini
je me sens bien
peut-être on pourrait se faire là
donc
avis c'est un exemple ou c'est un peu
l'arbre qui cache la forêt Isabelle
c'est un exemple évidemment si on a
besoin de d'image positives comme ça
pour les gamins je crois qu'ils ont
vraiment besoin d'avoir des images
positives maintenant ça peut pas suffire
c'est qu'il y a vraiment tellement
d'énergie dans les banlieues dans voilà
qu'il faut qu'on aille chercher
d'où l'importance d'ailleurs de ce que
moi j'essaye de faire sur enseignement
supérieur démocratisation d'enseignement
sup c'est ouvert à tous on est notre
société elle est trop elle est trop
figée elle est trop tubulaire vous êtes
vous ratez une coche
une étape bah tant pis voilà vous
décrochez et on arrive jusqu'à
0,058% d'une classe d'âge qui occupe 70%
des postes des conseils d'administration
des grands groupes et bon beaucoup des
cabinets ministériels et qui est plus
forte qu'elle n'a été alors que c'est il
y a enfin j'imagine que vous le voyez à
Trappes avec ce que vous faites sur le
foot c'est formidable mais il y a
vraiment une une énergie chez les jeunes
avec une génération quand même qu'il
faut qu'on à qui il faut qu'on s'adresse
et c'est pas des mots il faut qu'on
s'adresse à eux il faut qu'on leur dise
que votre avenir nous concerne qu'on
essaye de s'en occuper parce que
franchement on peut pas vous laisser les
choses comme ça et donc oui il faut des
éléments des des images positives et il
en est une magnifiquement mais au-delà
de l'image positif il faut vraiment y
ait beaucoup beaucoup de dispositifs au
combat tous ensemble tous ensemble dans
le bon sens positivement
parce que tous ceux qui vivent pour ceux
qui pour ceux qui le vivent que ça soit
Jamel Debbouze Anelka tous ces gens là
ils demandent qu'une chose c'est en
sortir parce qu'un moment donné voilà
confortablement confortablement installé
ailleurs qui attrapes
voilà ça me fait super plaisir de voir
Omar ça fait super plaisir de voir un
cas de Nicolas ou de voir Jamel
simplement ça peut être derrière le
prétexte à dire finalement ça marche
dans les banlieues on a des exemples et
quand on a sorti des exemples on clôt le
débat ça ça me gêne parce qu'il y a
encore du boulot et deuxième c'est un
peu les armes voilà la deuxièmement pour
moi j'ai pas vu que on devenait célèbre
parce qu'on était bon joueur bon
comédien ou bon voilà je pense qu'on
peut être un très bon restaurateur on
peut être un très bon éditeur on peut
être un très bon pharmacien il y en a
plein à Trappes
devient une ville de plus en plus
confortable bien Malandain a fait un
travail formidable sur cette ville et
objectivement trap d'aujourd'hui n'a
rien à voir avec le tram dia à 10 ou 15
ans ça évolue alors on arrive
malheureusement à la fin de cette
division il y avait un sujet dont j'ai
revu qu'on parle c'était de la GPA et la
PMA parce que ça fait un débat mais
malheureusement on en parlera peut-être
une prochaine fois est-ce qu'il y a un
fait dans l'actualité qui vous a frappé
il y a une chose qui m'amuse beaucoup
c'est le projet de Marisol Touraine de
de rendre obligatoire le paquet neutre
pour les paquets de cigarettes et il y a
un gouverneur d'Amérique du Nord de
Caroline du Nord qui lui dit si vous
faites ça nous on va mettre des
bouteilles neutres sur les bouteilles de
vin français donc voilà
je fais la même chose donc le champagne
le château Pétrus le Bourgueil même
bouteille
c'est l'intervention du pape François de
son synode ou globalement il y a un
apport très intéressant de la communauté
gay à la communauté chrétienne en
général et quand on met un petit peu
quand on relie un peu ces deux
événements alors je les mets pas
forcément bout à bout mais qu'on les
relie un petit peu quand même
la relecture
j'ai vraiment le sentiment qu'on est
parti dans un mouvement planétaire qui
laisse à penser que les mariages mixtes
pardon là dessus les mariages
contre le mariage pour tous avec la
position du pape il perte quand même un
peu on appuie non
pour voir ça Versailles dans le conseil
municipal il y en a qui perdent pas la
ligne l'autre jour en conseil municipal
le le groupe famille à venir Versailles
familles avenir a demandé rien moins que
le contrôle de l'orientation sexuelle
des intervenants dans les les écoles
soient public moi je peux s'il y a un
événement très rapidement il y a eu
quand même cette semaine un moment
important parce qu'on nous dit jamais
que ce qui va pas etc il y a eu un
moment très important c'est la loi sur
la transition énergétique on a une des
lois les plus progressives maintenant
d'Europe c'est formidable alors ça a été
masqué par l'épiphénomène de les quotas
mais l'essentiel mais l'essentiel mais
l'essentiel regardons l'essentiel
l'essentiel de cette semaine c'est quand
même la transition énergétique on va
sortir du nucléaire enfin ramener à 50%
avec une montée des énergies
renouvelables c'est beaucoup d'emplois
derrière j'ai c'est vraiment un moment
important et je m'en réjouis merci
infiniment Isabelle à tous et donc on se
retrouve dans 15 jours je crois que la
vitesse sera Robert Cadalbert